right it is now one o'clock and I will
open the organizational meeting of the
special committee on the department for
children youth and families welcome to
the committee I'm representative Leah
kosman and I'm the chair of this
committee and hereby open our first
meeting would you please stand and join
me for the Pledge of
Allegiance i al to the flag of the
United States of America and to the for
it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liy and justice for
all thank
you our first order of business is to
appoint our clerk I hereby appoint
representative Sandra Panic to be our
committee clerk this is a very important
job and I'm glad that we have you here
for it so thank you thank you and I
accept
wonderful
um and I have been appointed chair of
this committee by the speaker and
representative Lucy Weber has been
appointed the vice chair and we're glad
to have you our fir our next order of
business is an introduction to the
committee and why it was formed and what
we are charged with doing
from the speaker's office
um memo you'll see this bipartisan
committee it's actually in the um press
release this bipartisan committee on the
division for children youth and families
DCF is charged with considering all
matters on due process and practices
concerning
DCF my interest in this topic began
after I received complaints from
constituents who didn't feel there was
appropriate due process when it comes to
DCF child cust child protection cases I
heard from several individuals via
emails and I didn't really know how to
help them uh it wasn't my wheelhouse I'm
not on the children and family law
committee so I am happy to have members
of that committee here um I was
unfamiliar with the related statutes I
found out very quickly that the statutes
are vast and um sort of scattered
throughout the rsas and the DCF statutes
co-mingle with the family court statutes
and so I appointed people to the special
committee on the Family Court um and I I
started paying closer attention to these
matters because it seemed important then
beginning in October 2023 I started
receiving signed notices from some of
the people that outlin concerns uh that
DCF statutes proceedings and practices
are not constitutional and therefore
reform is needed the people instructed
me to form a committee to work toward
resolving the issues raised so I went to
the speaker and presented my concerns I
shared the notices with him as well as
some as some affidavits and anecdotes
and he agreed that it was worth
investigating and so a committee was
formed and here we are so thank you Mr
Speaker for
that uh I don't think it's missed by
anyone on this committee the gravity and
seriousness of the subject matter that
we're going to be looking at um the
courts have long recognized that the
right of parents to direct the
upbringing of their children is a
liberty interest protected by the due
process clause of the 14th am Amendment
of the United States
Constitution the New Hampshire
Constitution says in part one Article 15
no subject shall be arrested imprisoned
despoiled or deprived of his property
immunities or privileges put out of the
protection of the law exiled or deprived
of his life liberty or estate by the
Judgment of his peers or the law of the
land and the courts have held that law
of the land is synonymous with due
process children being vulnerable and
cherished members of our society which
we all all have an interest in the
protection of ought never needlessly be
taken from a family nor left in a
situation that brings them harm and the
complaints I've received are concerning
both of those
outcomes um and that they occur as a
result of deficiencies in due process so
in this work we're ensuring protection
of the innocent as well as the
accused next meeting we will as a group
come to know and understand what due
process is pursuant to the Constitution
bring your expertise your knowledge your
research and perhaps Witnesses we will
tease out what the Essential Elements of
due process are so that we're all on the
same page and before we begin our work
looking at processes and proceedings
involving
DCF then we'll find out through hearing
testimony and conducting work sessions
if and how statute policies and
procedures conflict with or deny do
process then we'll make recommendations
for reform if
necessary I'm going to give the
disclaimer now that we are working
toward redressing grievance to the
people here who claim due process
violations pursuing to Art part one
article uh 13 of the New Hampshire
Constitution the legislature can make no
retrospective laws so we cannot
legislate new outcomes for people who
are AG
grieved um we can't we can't open new
new cases or Rectify mistakes in Old
cases we're not re litigating anything
and and uh we're not we're not closing
cases that are open or changing outcomes
we are working towards the future and
improving the processes for the
people I will accept testimony for
members of the public at every hearing
except work sessions as I know the
people have stories to tell and they
took the time to be here so if they are
here they'll be offered an opportunity
to provide
testimony and with that I will um now
allow the committee members to to give
introductions I'll start um my name is
Leah kushman I serve the town of wear in
Hillsboro County District 28 this is my
second term as a state representative
and I serve on the health human services
and elderly Affairs committee and I'm a
registered nurse and a mother and we'll
go around this way and then we'll come
back um thank you madam chair I am
representative Erica Leon I represent
the town of dairy I currently serve as
the vice chairman of the Department of
the house Health Human Services and
elderly Affairs committee and this is
also my second
term my name is representative Sandra
Panic this is my first term I represent
Hillsboro district one in palum New
Hampshire and I'm representative Sheila
Sidell I represent gtown uh this is also
my first term I'm retired dental
hygienist and Mom and housewife or
wife we'll start over here thank you
thank you hi my name is Alicia Greg this
is my first term I represent Nashville
Ward 7 Hills Ro County um I also a mom a
wife and um juggle a few other things
but um I'm on the children and family
law committee and I've worked for about
eight years getting um uh domestic abuse
survivors into safer places so thank
you hello I'm representative Gabby Gman
and I also serve on the children and
family law committee um I represent
exiter on the Sea Coast and um I'm also
Mom and guardian to a 19-year-old son
with
autism um so I have special interest in
the disability
Community I'm Mary Jane walner and I'm
from conquer I serve Ward five you're
sitting right on the right on the line
of Ward five if you went up another
block you'd be in Ward five um I serve
on the finance committee and I'm on
division three and division three
actually works on the um children and
family um division's
budget you got significant
expertise uh my name is Lucy Weber uh
cheser 5 Walpole and Sari on the West
Coast
uh this is my ninth term in the house I
have three terms on the Judiciary
Committee one term on the children and
family law committee and three on Health
and Human Services which is where I now
sit um and one of my former lives uh was
as a teacher and the another of my
former lives was as an attorney uh but I
was an elder-law attorney not a well I
did divorces when I began
but it was in a long time ago and in
another state
um and then um there was one other thing
that I was going to talk about but oh
and I serve as a Kasabian lium
currently hi everybody I'm uh bat long
my district is in
Manchester uh the downtown area um uh I
serve on children and family this is my
ninth my ninth term um I was awarded EST
State at 3 years old
um lived on my own since I was 16 so I
kind of know what the process is and
state in the Hampshire as my mommy and
daddy and I am Jim kofalt I represent
Hillsboro County District 32 which is
Wilton Temple and new
ipswitch um I'm in my second term and I
sit on the health and human services and
elderly Affairs committee and the
fishing game committee
thank you very much um I look forward to
working with all of you and I appreciate
you all being here um our next order of
business is to introduce any agency or
um judicial branch Representatives who
might be here is there anyone present
from any of the
agencies would you like to come up to
the microphone and give an
introduction
I'm attorney Lisa masio I am the
associate child advocate for the state
so I am with the office of child
advocate not a service agency but an
oversight agency over dcyf in
part thank you very much for being here
I'm sure you'll have some very important
information for us to
know are there any members of the public
who wish to testify here
today okay step up to the microphone
state your
name goodno my name is SK
Murphy my name is Skip Murphy and I'm
here representing myself I have just
finished my fourth dcyf entanglement
stretching over 35
years um the latest one is probably the
driving force why I'm here followed by
the
Third my own two boys were put into The
Chins program the old
style in which we realized along with
help that they were just out of control
because emotional and
um processing difficulties they were
just literally too smart for their own
good and my wife was also suffering from
issues at the
time and it was
successful I'm glad to say that was the
old chins I reviewed the law concerning
the new chins I'm not
impressed
however I just returned my foster child
who also happens to me be my
granddaughter back to her family two
weeks ago during that time given the
that the focus of this committee is on
due process I'll be real short and just
bring up two examples
the law states that the cic the Child
Advocacy Center must do an interview
process along with the law enforcement
and a uh the investigative uh specialist
from
DCF at that point the family was way up
north in Coos County dcyf had already
called us back in May to come get my
granddaughter as we had been entangled
before
in helping out with my
grandson so I brought her to the lonia
DC lonia CAC for the
interview and in due process I was asked
to come in before they interrogated my
granddaughter told me what was going to
happen put a form in front of me and
said you have to sign this before we can
continue as is always my style I read
every single piece of paper paper that's
necessary whether it's in statute or
placed before me or that I have to turn
in and on it it was giving various
agencies access to the information
gathered by the interrogation and I
immediately said while we are in belnap
County she's from Coos why should bnap
County Sheriff's Department get access
to this and I clicked off a few others
given article eight of the New Hampshire
Constitution
they quickly gave me a new form where
those things removed but the second line
said the person that can sign this is
either a guardian or the biological
parents I was
neither but it I was insisted upon by
the DCU investigator that I had to sign
that paper or they couldn't do the
interrogation
this went on for 10 minutes until I
finally stood up and looked at the lonia
police detective who had been brought in
as the Leo and said you seem to be a
fine
gentleman but I have no compunctions
about trying to get to be your friend
riding in the backseat of your car after
I've said I am not a guardian I have no
legal custody of my
grandchild I can't sign this form yet I
was given no due process and as I got up
to leave the DCU worker said well I'll
call back to the office and find out if
I can find another shortcut so that we
can continue our work that we have to
do that was
wrong the chair made the statement
of that other people have complained
about due process and the lack thereof
as far as the the rules within DCF and
the state
statutes but there's also a third thing
that I would ask that this committee
consider is what
happens even when things are compliant
with each other what do you do for due
process when people ignore how they are
supposed to
act which was done in my part and in my
and at that
point there are other stories that I
could tell you but I know that time is
short here but those are the two main
points I wanted to bring up to put
before the committee that I hope that
you look into and I have no problem in
giving more stories nor any problems in
answering any of your
questions thank you are there any
questions will you take questions
absolutely any questions go ahead thank
you madam chairwoman and thank you for
being here and telling your story we
appreciate it I just wanted
clarification so um what you said on the
due process what to do when people
ignore what they're supposed to do
specifically are you talking about the
DCF or the law enforcement or who who
are the people the law enforcement
person kind of smiled and he nodded when
I said what I did about the back seat
trying to make light of
situation the DCF investigative
specialist glowered at me okay and so
did the CAC person who just wanted to
get her job
done I will will be filing
grievances I already did a right to know
for the paperwork but given all of the
issues that my granddaughter has and I
had to deal with I couldn't do anything
at the time I'm going to revisit it I'm
not a person who likes it when people
try to do the wrong things to anyone and
when you make it personal I
remember but I would rather see the
committee be able to make its
recommendations to make that stop from
happening to somebody else I'm well
versed in what this goes on uh at the
state
level I put myself however in the
personage of somebody whose only idea of
DCF is like the IRS they'll take my
money but DCF will take my kids and they
have no recourse because they don't know
the law they don't know the practices
they don't know the people they don't
know the
processes that should also be part of of
due process and they never
know you're
welcome go ahead representative Gman
thank you
um so the important piece is your
granddaughter is that the child the
grand um what happened after that in
terms of was your granddaughter able to
access any services or anything because
obviously there was a crisis going on
it took some time and I'm not trying to
throw a bucket of water on DC wife as a
whole I will tell you that two of the
people I worked intimately with her case
worker out of the Berlin office as well
as the foster child
liaison that I talk to all the time was
fantastic so there are good people
working within the division it turned
out
that I'm trying to figure out a way to
say this
short my son and my daughter-in-law are
both
vets she is
disabled having fallen down a flight of
stairs on the USS Ronald Reagan during
her service and she has some
injuries
they the division decided that they were
going to go after her for
neglect because they believed that my
son abused my
granddaughter
when she has a history of lying both I
and the Guilford Middle School have
corroborated those lies she has
emotional outbursts she has a history
and we'll tell you quite easily I hit my
siblings my
three-year-old
um um sister my 2-year-old uh brother
and my older autistic very autistic
older
sister the first day of school she had
an
outburst one of the one of the
boys and when they were outside simply
asked her where did you come from she
heard a far different question that set
her off thankfully the principal was out
there and saw the whole outburst
when she came
home she had a major
escalation and at that point my wife and
I had gone through past Kinship
Caregivers to General foster parents to
Skilled care parents because we knew
what some of her issues were given her
behavioral specialist at D with
Hitchcock as well as emergency and
crisis we went Whole Hog we did almost a
100 hours of training in a month and a
half to be able to help her out
she threatened to kill her mother
threatened to kill her father threatened
to kill her sister her other sister and
her brother she was vibrating so hard I
was sitting about 10 feet from her she
was yelling at my wife who was five feet
from her and I was thinking gosh I'm
going to get in trouble for what my son
got in trouble for which was to grab her
to restrain her to keep from hitting
her brother and sisters more I was going
to have to protect my wife yet that's
what the school district did and
dropping a dime on my son and
daughter-in-law accusing him of abuse
because she ended up with a little Nick
on her
neck and my daughter-in-law for uh
neglect of preventing that
abuse well I think the Judge thought
otherwise once I get up on the stand
because I experienced all the same
things and I was able to let them
know and go from there I mean I
documented absolutely everything I
formed basically a task group of
behavioral specialists up in Dartmouth
all of the people at the Guilford Middle
School behavioral specialist there her
casew worker there the principal there
the counselor and several DCF people
everybody always knew everything and
that was the key and I wish more people
would do that unfortunately from what I
hear most people don't know enough to do
that so parents who are getting
entangled with
DCF probably need a little bit of
training of how to deal with DCF and how
to take care of the law because most
people can't afford a lawyer and don't
know where to
start I was an exception because I do
politics um
um but as far as due process is
concerned to come
back there are a number of things that
also other things that went wrong as
well and I'm happy to help the committee
understand what they are with concrete
examples that I can back
up so does that answer your
question another question representative
Greg thank you um Madame chairwoman
would it be possible you seem to have
some pretty extensive information um to
even like give us written testimony to
email the committee so that way we can
kind of re I don't know if anybody else
is interested in that but it seems like
there's a lot going on it might be
easier to um process and kind of
understand and stuff if you had a
written I I that you be will sh happy to
do that some of it's already out there
on the internet okay in full
disclosure I own and founded granic
ro.com
DCF is nonpartisan
and I've only written about my part of
it I've also written about my
grandson who we ended up having to adopt
that this was my third DC F tangl
because my younger son had served a year
in Afghanistan with 101st Airborne as a
uh door
kicker he came home with severe
PTSD took up with and was
self-medicating when he came home took
up with some somebody who was doing the
same they split then he found out he was
going to be a dad the day that my
grandson was
born he was in a lock down VA Ward
because he had made threats against
himself and it took him a long time
during the year
reconciliation he realized he was not
going to be able to get his act together
nor was the mother who abandoned him
when my wife went up the second day I
learned that DC wife has a permanent
office up at Dartmouth Hitchcock Lebanon
she pleaded with my wife to please take
my grandson once he got out of ncu
because he was born with opiates and
alcohol in his bloodstream he has been
diagnosed with fetal alcohol syndrome
and a few other things but fortunately
he's doing very well but before that
ended my son made
the effort I will give up my parental
rights if you give up yours so that my
mother and father can
adopt there were things about that trial
that I or that reconciliation
process that there were things that DCF
did badly in that and I'd be happy to to
write about those so as you can tell
I've had a lot of experience on this
side of DCF again there were good people
during that process as well
and there were some bad people
especially a couple of that tried to
violate my constitutional
rights so again you may have laws and
Norms set up but if people aren't
willing to follow those everybody is in
trouble not only the the parents and the
child but also the good
guys because the bad apples
spoil so I can do that thank you and
representative Leon you had a question
um yes sorry thank you madam chair and
thank you so much for coming and sharing
these experiences it seems that you've
had a lot of experience and seen the
importance and the benefits of what DCF
does but how they can do it better and
is this sort of the the the the value of
what they do in order to make sure the
children are in the safe situation but
you would just want to make sure that
everybody's rights are protected in this
process absolutely and that's part of
the process in fact the
the foster parent leaz Z has asked me to
come up to the Berlin office just to
give a talk to the other folks now semi
serious uh but it it hasn't happened yet
but know I'd be happy to do that for
anybody and in any office because there
is good and bad um and I know that a lot
of the
dcfc people read the harmony uh incident
see the dregs of society they were also
good parents that have had uh bad
information passed about them and that
neither one is
good any further questions from the
committee representative
Weber thank you madam chair and thank
you for being here today and taking my
question and I'm very sorry for the
difficulties that you have had to go and
and very thankful that you're looking
after some kids who need you um
the question that I have is a very
specific one going back to the first
incident that you talked about with the
lonia CAC and I understand your concerns
about being asked to sign something that
you were being asked to sign illegally
improperly uh but what I wanted to know
was did that CAC interview ever take
place and when and under what
circumstances well apparently the DC
worker found a workaround SL
shortcut and bypass that form because I
never signed it and they did do the uh
the interview from what I know now what
use would it have been at the time I
didn't know later on having had her at
our house for eight and a half
months I'm bet you she they didn't get
quite a straight story because that's
how she was
unfortunately however to complete that
story they realized that the the good
caseworker realized that the parents
weren't the problem the child and her
artistic older sister severely needed
intensive in-house
services and made it happen and that's
what's going on right now so that was a
good thing it took a process to get
there if the investigator had done the
due process who never talked to the
parents beforehand the school counselor
had never talked to the parents before
beforehand they just dropped the dime
and I got the Panic called you have to
pick up Julie from the school because
they won't let me see
her that was a in my understanding an
unethical if not legal uh abreg of due
process thank you you're quite quite
welcome any further oh representative
copal yes thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you for taking my question so at
the beginning of your opening statement
you said and those are the two main
points that I want to make and I I I
tend to keep going I think I gathered
that they were people don't always know
what their rights are and that people
don't necessarily believe that they have
they don't know where to go
for for redress if they if they don't
feel like they're getting due process
did I capture those correctly that's one
okay and the other one is when you have
government employees who fail to to
follow the law and their own regulations
that's a problem how you deal with that
from a due process perspective which is
the you know what this committee is
supposed to do I don't have an
answer I'm not sure that anybody when is
going to have an answer given that
somebody can go Rogue I need to get this
done I'm going to do the shortcuts I
don't care what the law or the
regulations
say but I think it's something that has
to be looked
at any further questions from the
committee representative long thank you
madam
chairwoman and thank you Mr Murphy for
your
testimony um now the current relation
you're having with DCF has been positive
is what I'm hearing is that
correct with respect to the case worker
for my granddaughter as well as my
liaison as a foster parent
absolutely in fact um we have told them
that we would be willing to take more
foster kids especially babies when we
owned to daycare my wife made herself
the baby teacher so and we understand
that there is a need for that so yes it
is positive and that we're willing to do
it again after all if you spend all that
time and training you're not just going
to say 100 hours just for one child
right uh follow for me yeah the um have
you had the opportunity to discuss with
them the incident you had at the lonia
CAC oh yes and and how how did that how
did that um I don't know if they ever
did anything with that nothing was ever
told to me as I said earlier during my
testimony I'm going to do something
about it okay uh and one more followup
if I may followup thank you uh are you
um are you familiar with the DCF uh
maybe 18 months ago or two years or two
years started a constituents relations
depart division yes and my
daughter-in-law did contact them because
of some of the
irregularities um a couple were solved a
couple uh were
not um but I had tipped her off that
that office existed and that she needed
to contact it
okay super so I know that the lady
behind me who introduced herself to you
is part of that office I believe um no
she's not no that's a different office
okay yeah
sorry
inde two different okay so uh you know I
should go back and ask my
daughter-in-law um what remains
outstanding at this point okay super
thank
you and any further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony and just for the record I do
have a question are you um where are you
from I am from Guilford Gilford thank
you thank you very much for all of your
time and your
questions and with that is there anyone
else in the audience who wishes to give
testimony
today seeing none I will turn back to
our committee um I'll give an
opportunity now if anyone has questions
comments thoughts on our where we're
going from here represented
W actually just comment you know sitting
in children and family
law people come before you they're
frustrated we're the ones they want to
be talking to
however they're so frustrated that we
don't articulate a specific issue it
it's five issues um and it's hard it's
hard for us to to you know we that out
um so if somehow some way we could grab
an issue and and work through that and
then grab the next issue um that that
would be helpful in articulating
Solutions better you thank you and if I
may I I I totally agree I think we need
to um eventually have like a bulleted
list of what the the most common
concerns are um once we establish for
the committee our understanding of what
due process is so that's what next
um the next meeting will be on so once
we have that if you want if you all want
to be thinking about those things um
different categories of complaints um
that we can separate things out into and
help us be organized um that would be
great and I agree with you I had the
same experience when I was trying to
help um understand what these issues are
and I was talking to constituents and
people in the community and I would sit
for two hours with someone and it was
very hard to get to the nuts and bolts
of what the problems were with due
process and so um someone had told me if
you um that they could put it in an
affidavit then they could use it later
so I was helping people to write
affidavits I was helping them boil down
their their issue before we pursued this
Committee just to um kind of get it all
of their thoughts organized and on paper
and um in preparation for if they wanted
to take further action so I totally
understand and I I think to that end um
if anyone is going to bring testimony
written testimony to accompany your
verbal testimony is greatly
appreciated representative Le um thank
you madam chair um as far as um getting
an information about what the common
concerns are I'd be curious if the
office of the child advocate and
potentially DCF constituent relations if
they know what the most common
complaints are if they could can provide
any information they already have on
that that would be helpful I don't want
to task you with a new job but I'm
guessing there's probably at least some
casual list um if not a formal list of
what the common complaints are and it
would be really helpful for us to know
what you're seeing and we then we can
compare that with what we see I think
that's a great idea thank you
representative
Weber thank you well I'm I'm seeing a
couple of threads here and uh the first
one that I bring is just the concern
that I think you've actually already
articulated it but I see it in a
slightly different way which is on we're
balancing two very very important
concerns one is the sanctity of the
family and our desire to keep family
units together and whole and on the
other hand our desire to make sure that
children are
safe
and I want to acknowledge the very
difficult work that DCF does
because nobody is perfect and one
mistake in that
direction either damages a family or
damages a child's safety or both and
none of that is anything that we want to
see so the work is difficult to begin
with SEC so so I just wanted to
acknowledge that because we are
balancing those two critical interests
um which is a basis when you look at the
interest for what processes then do um
and that gets us to this due
process thing because I see two strands
here one is my understanding of the
concept of legal due process which I see
as being more for the courts than anyone
else but it certainly percolates down
through everybody's
dealings uh and the other thing is the
issue of simple structural
issues which are things that can be
discussed and addressed and if we find
that it's a oneoff because somebody was
having a bad day that's one thing but if
it is something that is an ongoing issue
problem that we can help
work on Solutions um that's another
thing and I I speak as one who was on
the child abuse fatalities commission
back in
2015 and I came with a list of the six
or seven other entities that have
studied DCF and DCF issues since then
and um I think it's very important that
the work of examination go forward um
but I also want to be sure that at the
end of it what we're doing is
generating a an action
list if there are things that we can
think of that are useful um and and that
committee actually did so um you know we
start where we are now and go forward
but I want to be sure that we're not too
formulaic
in I think it would be very very easy
for us to get tied up in whatever
everybody's notion of due process is to
the detriment of
practical understandings and
solutions so that's my
take thank you any other comments from
the committee I will make a comment uh
our committee researcher is kind enough
to be um employing a uh research inquiry
on the past commissions and committees
that have looked at dcy so she'll be
bringing us that information and I would
request also Christina um Christina Dyer
is our committee researcher everyone I'm
sorry I didn't introduce you Christina
she's a very important person on this
committee um I I would request if you
would mind doing a research project on
constitutional due process and what the
elements of that are thank
you any
further seeing no further discussion
uh we can schedule the next meeting we
were looking at March 4th and March 8th
and I did get a lot of feedback that uh
either of those dates were good but that
was probably a week or two ago yeah so
um tell me how it's looking for you
all 11 okay and on the eight I am
still
I am I am clear
until and
ie on the eth okay how about the fourth
the fourth sounds like it might be
better still do one morning um well
considering the morning representative
Weber said that the morning before 11 on
the 4th would work for her I have a
limit I have a engagement on the morning
of the 8th so if folks are not available
in the afternoon that day it seems like
that day is a little
conflicted I'm
available on the 8th or the fourth
okay okay all right it seems like the
fourth is the most accommodating to
everyone um I apologize that we won't be
you know sometimes it's inevitable that
not everyone will make it um but I will
put in a request to see if we can
schedule for that morning the four 10 n
nine nine
okay
yes and with that I will close the the
yeah actually I just uh wanted there's a
dcyf advis oversight committee that uh
representative uh sidel and myself sit
on
um I don't know what Avenue that may be
helpful in uh just keeping them back of
youre okay and and there are several
other current entities as
well oh yes let's have a discussion on
who we should bring in so we probably
you can speak to DCF oversight committee
since you serve on it if you wanted to
present some information on what you the
advisory committee advisory yeah um and
we we want to hear
from
um the
constituent Services uh constituent
relations maybe from DCF we do want to
hear from the Department in general so
we should put out an invitation to
them um the CH and the the office of the
child advocate it will very helpful and
determining because one of the things
is that I think we all hear loud and
clear is people don't know where to go
when something has not turned out the
way they think it ought to and uh there
are
multiple Avenues but they're not
necessarily that easy to find but the
office of the child advocate is one of
the things that came out of the
commission that I was on in in 2015 that
we're very glad is here
here great that's wonderful and there
was um I did want to send pass out um
just the notice because it does go over
the concerns with due process um that I
rece these notices I re I received
probably upwards of 150 of them and they
do just kind of outline um the
Constitutional issues that some people
are seeing two three four five six um so
I did want you all to have a copy of
that also
it would be great if you could provide
this in electronic format sure I can
send that out electronically
yep representative and also um I believe
representative weers on Health and Human
Services oversight if we if that is
becomes relevant to what we do as well
or does it not deal with that okay
because um although it although it does
deal with dcyf issues what it normally
does is it's dealing with the followup
to legislation that we've already passed
and how it's being implemented so
um and it deals with a great number of
things other than DCF so thank you I
just figured knowing which areas are
more relevant to it and those are not as
helpful so thank you for that
information and I'm sure you can thread
your experience there through whatever
discussions are relevant
also right any other suggestions for uh
entities that we should bring in I I
would like to speak to someone
representing uh the family court that
deals with these cases so I'd like to
put out an invitation to them any others
Christina
great thank
you all right and with that I will close
the meeting thank you all thank
you